[Music]
hi i'm sarah hendricks and this is our
little dream shop lady and larder
we are a small actually tiny cheese shop
based here in los angeles california and
we specialize in cheese and cured
meatboards we serve it with an array of
fresh seasonal produce dried fruit nuts
olives cornichon we've always found that
what's in season is what tastes best
the foundation of all great cheese
boards is always the products you choose
to put on it so you always want to
select a couple of cheeses we work in
odd numbers we find those are visually
pleasing you always want to have a
variety of texture and flavor we always
recommend getting something that's a
safe bet for your crowd which for most
people is a good solid cheddar made with
cow's milk everyone loves cheddar it's
always a win and then once you get your
cheddar you can add a couple more
adventurous options like a funky blue
cheese or a creamy goat cheese or even a
sheep's milk cheese once you have your
cheeses down then you're going to lay
your cured meats when selecting your
meats we go with the same golden rule
variety taste and texture get a couple
of different size formats larger smaller
spicy different flavor profiles and then
you'll have an array of items on the
board once you get everything put
together instead of laying all of your
meats flat on the board we like to take
larger ones and fold them in a variety
of different ways which i'm going to
show you right now with prosciutto our
larger cured meats we like to make a
little bit of what we call like a ribbon
and we run those just down the middle of
the board always keeping them airy and
light and not too compacted
next when you're laying the smaller
circular format salami we lay the
tiniest ones flat and overlapped just
like so around the edges they create a
great border for your for your platters
or boards
and then with the stuff that's medium or
large in size is we like to fold those
in a couple of different ways the first
way i'm going to show you is just like a
deck of cards you fold them in half and
arrange them in your hand like you're
holding a hand of cards in a poker game
another way that i'm gonna fold meats
today is here like a flower you fold
them in half and then in half again
being careful not to squish them
together too much so that again they
stay nice and airy and light
we're gonna take all of the negative
open space in the middle of the board
and add the rest of the accoutrements
accoutrements are all those delicious
little things that pair well with your
cheeses and meats so your fruit your
nuts your olives and when it comes to
laying out the accoutrements we like to
place things that pair well together
near each other once the fresh fruit is
laid then we do the dried fruit followed
by the nuts be sure not to put rolly
things like olives and nuts at the edges
so that when you're transferring it they
don't roll off
once you have your board just how you
want it then you finish it with final
touches and garnishes go ahead and head
over to the herb section at your grocery
store and grab flowering rosemary or
thyme or edible flowers just make sure
that everything that you place on your
board is edible and safe to eat
here at lady and larder our signature
garnish is usually a bit of wild
chamomile we love chamomile because it
adds an extra whimsy touch when
garnishing the boards
we have a golden cheese rule and that is
that you should always serve your cheese
and cured meats at room temperature so
if you're getting ready to entertain at
six pull your board out at five o'clock
so that it has an hour to come up to
room temp
and here we are
finish board
if you are ever worried about getting
invited back to an adventure party we
recommend bringing one of these this
board will be the showstopper at
friendsgiving game night or any of your
holiday events this year
another one of our favorite things to
make at the shop are cakes made out of
cheese you heard it cheesecakes people
love to order these for their birthdays
gifts weddings baby showers all of their
big events if you don't have a big sweet
tooth this is the cake for you the most
important part of selecting cheese for a
cheesecake is that you select cheeses of
different sizes you want to ensure that
the tears get smaller as you build
upwards we recommend using bloomy rind
softer cheeses those ones are all easy
to break down and serve at home now for
the fun part we get to add all the
seasonal garnishes and fresh honeycomb
right now it's fall so we're going to be
using a variety of different things we
found at the farmer's market including
miniature apples pomegranate figs and
golden raspberries other options at
different times of year include things
like fresh citrus viola flowers
you name it every time of year there's
something special that you can use to
garnish a cheesecake we love making
these cakes because they bring joy to
any celebration
remember there's no wrong way to do this
just relax have fun and enjoy sharing
these with your friends and family
oh yes
[Music]
you